what is happening there reject
nation greg here today holding
down the fort still while john is out
of commission recovering from surgery
for getting a knuckle sandwich to his teeth
that's why he was missing one get it knuckles
is a family-friendly joke for this family-friendly
movie guys we got ourselves a sonic the hedgehog 2
final trailer i'm excited to watch this
man i thought the first trailer was
awesome it looks way more exciting and cinematic
already you got to be trapped in here with me for
just a tiny bit longer i promise and yeah
if you guys can hit the like button that'd
be very much appreciated anyway let's see this
let's see this thing all right fine you can go
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry life
or death situation i need you to use
the ring to save me like right now
my god oh boy oh wedding wrecked ah hawaii i
just hope we are not too late oh lord there
are two of them now what's happening
okay quick version robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate power master
aberrate we need to get it
back for the world is doomed
you rock some kind of
space porcupine i am an echidna warrior ooh badass
man hedgehog it's time to say goodbye to humanity
oh [ __ ] welcome to the new norm oh what a moment
bad time to say this but i
don't actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your uh
someone call an uber it's cold
in here let's turn up the heat
oh awesome oh so it's not a skateboarding
snowboarder she's running pieces that's cool
i'll break the winter soldier fear not citizens
you are terrible at this your
negative attitude is not helping
we stick together no matter what
that looks pretty imposing whoa
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one unstoppable
they're watching a dbz fight man that death egg
looks insane i love that imposing shot where he's
just like this big shadow with the red eyes at
the top so good this looks so much better than
the first one i overall enjoyed the first one but
this looks like a major step up you know what that
last part kind of reminded me of tell me if this
flashed to your mind at all do you remember the
episode of pokemon when pikachu fought riochu
and raichu just kept like beating his ass and
then pikachu had realized that he could out speed
him while raichu was more powerful that's kind of
what i thought of there dbz versus the pikachu
versus raichu fight where it seems like knuckles
obviously more powerful however sonic might
be able to out strategize him and outspeed him
because he's clearly like dodging him a bunch just
a little food for thought anyway yeah this trailer
just gave me some more of what i loved about
the first one it's exciting it's thrilling the
word that weirdly keeps coming to mind for me is
it just looks so much more cinematic the peril
actually feels really felt one of those shots in
there was so ominous the death egg where it's like
this big looming shadow over sonic it's really
threatening and imposing red eyes and that's all
that's really colorful about that silhouette
shot of the death egg at the very bottom you
see like sonic he's like limping his way he's
really worn out and tired and just beaten down
limping towards the emerald he's all like dirtied
up just seems like it's gonna be a real struggle
for sonic something that the first trailer seemed
to lean in on was how sonic was you know trying
to be more of a hero right now and i'm kind of
curious what his journey here might be because
like in the first one a lot of it dealt with like
run away from your problems now face your problems
and then here i'm sort of curious to see like what
sonic's arc ultimately might be would emotional
challenges behold him at this particular moment
in time there's a popular theory going around
and i'm wondering if it's going to be infused in
here at all i'm like i haven't read a single damn
leak about this movie so i don't know if there's
any leaks out there about it but a popular theory
because like when you're in angel city if i'm
not mistaken in angel city where knuckles and
sonic are versing each other all those statues
are resembling longhawk who we didn't see die
at the beginning of the first sonic movie but she
still sacrificed herself so it wasn't an on-screen
death she could very much be alive and the common
theory that i'm hearing is like maybe the echidna
went after longhawk because she's somehow
connected to the master emerald in some way i
don't really know like the ins and outs or details
of why that would line up but then you see all
this owl imagery and i feel like you got to bring
that back you got to bring that back home like why
was longhawk really protecting sonic i really want
to see that be more fleshed out and perhaps you
know especially with establishing in the trailer
that knuckles as an echidna warrior that he might
learn something like you're the people who killed
my mom or the one who protected me like he might
have some type of revenge vengeance driven motive
a vengeance you might have some type of like
revenge motive because of how serious he seems to
be taking it how personal this seems to really be
for him and then you got these moments here with
dr robotnik that also threw me for a loop a little
bit i know there's been some tv spots that are out
there i haven't seen them so i don't know how much
of this is completely brand new but for me it's
been pretty new when you're looking at dr robotnik
when he's coming out of this shop it looks like
he's from my understanding feel free to correct me
because i'm by no means a self-proclaimed sonic
expert i thought like with the master emerald
that that power be used solely for his machinery
something along the lines were just like the death
egg right and then here it looks like somehow his
body was managed to like draw some power from it
or fuse with it or interface with it in some way
like i don't really know how he's doing any of
that but that looks cool that looks sinister it
would seem like the plot of this would probably go
something like this when it comes to what the
finale might be and if it is this case i'm so
glad they're not showing it in the trailers
because they're really letting it seem like
hey you got knuckles and dr robotnik going after
sonic that seems to be like they're keeping at the
focus i imagine at some point here knuckles
and sonic kind of like bvs or any of these
like versus movies and knuckles and sonic would
eventually come to some kind of understanding
and then knuckles would see that he sided with the
wrong person he sided with dr robotic the one he
shouldn't be with and then they along with tails
would be fighting dr robotnik at the end of this
movie while he's in the death act like sonic looks
like he cannot take on the death egg by himself
so he would probably need some help and i imagine
he would get it from knuckles and tails have them
in the movie and then the sequel you could get
that you know and then set up shadow sonic i'm
sure i think a lot of people really want that and
with like having uh the gun army involved in here
feel like they're establishing some little seeds
for getting shadow sonic to get involved in this
franchise now i mean like i'm loving the action
scenes i'm loving everything that we're seeing
the expansions of it i feel like calling this
final trailer is a relief because i think this
is plenty this is enough and it still looks
like funny you know it doesn't look hilarious
but it still looks funny and charming like very
amusing still feels like a family friendly movie
while being something that even more adults can
enjoy one thing though that i'm hoping is just so
strong in reserve for the movie because it's going
to be such a highlight i'm hoping it's a highlight
sometimes and this is like a minor critique
more of a nitpick more than anything else they
don't really showcase tales so much or at least
i don't feel like they're really promoting tails
all that much i want to get like a better sense
of the chemistry between sonic and tails because
sometimes when i'm watching the trailer it really
feels like someone in a voiceover booth talking
like i'm not feeling the chemistry between
them when that's such a vital part i really
hope that that really clicks because while
i'm sure it's gonna be good and fine i want
it to be something that you walk away from this
movie going hey that's sonic and tails man they
were they were a great duo they were really fun
together but anyway yeah this is a great trailer
it's just as strong as the first one even better
actually thanks for being here guys appreciate
you sticking around me and uh hey subscribe
leave a like button last but not least stupid
i'm mariam i just want to shut you up and give you
a real sincere one right now i posted some video
the other day and you sent me a message on
twitter that i i thought was like very like
it put me at ease it made me feel really calm at
the time i really needed to read that so i just
want to say uh thank you for um being honest with
me and expressing that because that truly did um
you know made me feel made me feel relaxed and for
to go from anxious to feeling relaxed is just a
real gift so i want to thank you for just all
the support that you've been giving us and for
opening up your heart to me in so
many ways like your your real gem
your real joy you're my master emerald there
tighter than sonic love you dear thank you